you're not gonna believe this but a new
study has found that married people are
actually happier if you watch sitcoms
that doesn't seem to be the case but
yeah
a study there was a study on it let's
take a look this was reported in The New
York Times
being married makes people happier and
more satisfied with their lives and
those who remain single those who
consider their spouse or partner to be
their best friend get about twice as
much life satisfaction from marriage as
others people have the capacity to
increase their happiness levels by
finding support in long-term
relationships so I thought this was kind
of interesting because first off yeah
everything in TV seems to show married
people miserable right they're always
miserable the guy wants to go have fun
and he's just a goofball and the woman's
overbearing and wants to ruin his day
and we've also done tons of stories on
how Millennials and people mostly
younger than us don't even want to get
married they're getting married much
later now in their 30s there's very few
people getting married in their 20s so I
thought this kind of flips things on its
head for conventionalism so historically
in any of these studies come out men
report higher levels of happiness when
they're married across all
socio-economic barriers across all races
so we've already known for some time
that men report being happier when
they're married maybe that's because
they have somebody to assist them in
things somebody that is take care of
them they found perhaps a mother and
women report being less happy they don't
stay the same women are unhappy err yeah
it's starting to shift a little bit I
think as we start to look for more
partners people in this New York Times
study that described themselves happy
while married also tended to describe
their relationship as a friendship so to
feel like you have somebody who has your
back and as your peer and as your equal
of course that would make somebody happy
to have somebody who's constantly there
for you and I think the further you feel
separated from your partner when it's a
relationship either of convenience and
the person is not your friend you're
going to be less happy because that's
more work right so this friend
relationship thing is kinda interesting
and it was making me think of when Harry
Met Sally the famous line of how men and
women just can't be friends at least a
straight man and a straight woman can't
be friends with that yes please go ahead
oh no I just take issue with the notion
that men and women can't be friends that
sexual tension is always gonna get in
the way that is just not the case
I have so many guy friends my boyfriend
would disagree but
but that doesn't mean that I'm not
friends with them that's beside it then
if the guys if the guy is like yeah
we're friends but I would totally bang
you then you're not joking
overwhelms the interaction every time
that we have like you know a meal or see
each other it's like genuine friendship
that goes beyond the physical attraction
I I think entirely yeah I do think that
there's also something to be said for
two things one maturity right you get to
be more mature and I think you
ultimately find that you're willing to
sacrifice the amplitude of an
unpredictability of relationships and
dating for something that's more
consistent maybe you never get to the
same highs as when you're dating and
you're infatuated and you're falling for
someone but you never have to deal with
the lows of breakups and you know other
devastating things that happen when
you're when you're doing that right that
the contentment level may never reach
here but at least it's never reaching
here and you're just there and when you
will get to a point where you just want
to put up the [ __ ] anymore you're
gonna be happy that you found that right
and I would guess that for many married
couples the happiness level does get
there too because there's all kinds of
other rewards that they can get together
either through our children or doing
whatever that yeah you know a single
person maybe can't download well this
study seems to closely match like
Maslow's period pyramid it seems that
once you are able to be self actualized
in your life like you're not searching
for food or shelter it once your
socio-economic bracket is such that you
can search for self-actualization and
happiness you tend to find partners that
you can also be friends with it's not
just a matter of survival and finding
someone to not only procreate with but
just put the rent with and if you look
at this New York time study that
actually is reflected in this says that
people that have a little bit more means
a little more flexibility in their lives
tend to report that they're happier but
only when the relationship was at the
point where this wasn't out of necessity
that they've chosen this relationship
and it's not you know scrambling to be
with somebody right alright so last
night on this do you think part of it
also is that it just doesn't seem cool
to be like oh I'm married and happy like
when you say that it just doesn't seem
cool as versus like I'm single I can do
whatever the hell I want I can do drugs
and go out and have sex really what like
they said there's a cool factor there so
people this is always greener elements
yeah so and I think that you know more
and more people are whether or not
they're married if they're in sort of a
long-term partnership you you see that
as very unavailable if you're in a
short-term partnership
maybe rocky or if you're single I think
that there's there's certainly something
enviable and that and free wants to
strive for that yeah ultimately are you
married are you single are you happy are
you miserable let us know in the
comments right now